hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and this is big
as the second major war arc in mha
escalates the heroes tried to implement
izawa's master plan to split up the
villains and defeat perfect shigaraki
however shigaraki is even stronger than
they had imagined he has powers they did
not anticipate and the heroes are about
to pay a high price for their
miscalculation to make things worse deku
is not in a position to save his friends
from shigaraki and this is getting
really ugly really quickly so let's get
into it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our mha videos and you want to see
more in the future just leave a quick
like and comment it only takes a second
but it really helps with that youtube
algorithm and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you just haven't had a chance to
subscribe yet do me a quick favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications it is a completely
free and very real way of supporting
this channel directly finally this video
will of course contain boku do hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned now the
previous three chapters served as a
setup for this incredible battle and in
the latest chapter the battle really
gets going we learned all the specifics
of izaba's secret plan back in chapter
344
and we know that isawa anticipated that
all for one would be relying on search
to track the location of all the
strongest heroes this would lull him
into a false sense of security once he
realized that deku was within his reach
and the other heroes were far away and
so aizawa made plans to use nato and
warpgate to get one over on all for one
and he also used shinzo's quirk to
trickle from one into meeting aoyama and
deku in the first place it turns out
that shinso was able to improve his
quirk and now he can actually make the
people that he is controlling talk and
carry on a normal conversation which is
something that he couldn't do before so
it was in fact shinso who had ensured
that aoyama and his mother could speak
to all for one over the phone without
making over one thing that they were
being deceitful back on the battlefield
the heroes activated a bunch of trapped
cages that were able to seal the
villains away and therefore separate
them into smaller groups these cages
couldn't even hold the villains for more
than 3 seconds but 3 seconds is all that
the heroes needed in order for the next
stage of their plan to take effect
before the villains could fully break
out of the cages the heroes were able to
shove them into giant warp gates and
teleport the different groups of
villains into completely different
locations far away from each other this
separating of the villains was a key
component of aizawa's plan from the
start and i can't stress enough what a
chad nato monoma has become and how
important he is now to the entire plan
and he only gets more important as the
battle unfolds but more on that later
everything goes according to plan at
first except for one major hiccup deku
doesn't end up where he's supposed to be
because he is pulled into one of the
other warp gates against his will by the
relentless yandere himiko toga so deku
ends up at the same location as ochako
tsuyu and gang orca and there they are
facing off against toga several nomu and
other villains ochako and the others are
shocked that deku is here because he was
supposed to be at the same location as
shigaraki and deku is shocked too
because his danger sense did not warn
him that toga was about to pull him into
a portal because of that he didn't
anticipate this happening and so he
ended up here but why didn't danger
sense activate is it because toga really
doesn't mean to do any harm to deku or
is it because her sense of right and
wrong is just so warped that danger
sense did not even pick up on her true
intentions i'll come back to that later
because first we have to talk about the
other locations and the ongoing battle
against the newly perfected shigaraki
all for one is transported to the
location of the gunga mountain villa the
former secret hideout of the paranormal
liberation front there he and a bunch of
lesser villains are challenged by
endeavour hawks kamui woods pixie bob
tokoyami and others dobby and shoto
along with many others are transported
to kamino next to the famous almighty
statue and that statue now has a sign
that reads hero must die clearly the
sign game has escalated quickly and the
mood on the streets in japanese cities
is getting more and more bitter finally
shigaraki is transported to the ua
itself which has been transformed into a
freaking flying fortress surrounded by a
powerful electric barrier the heroes who
are there include best genius bakugou
miruko sun eater nejire and headshot and
of course deku was also supposed to be
there but he ended up with toga instead
and think about it if they were willing
to risk deku and shigaraki being in the
same place even though shigaraki is
determined to steal one for all then
that means that the plan really needed
deku to succeed the plan needed deku so
badly that they were willing to risk
losing one for all and now they don't
have deku and that is not good shigaraki
who is openly referred to as the
greatest villain in history in this
chapter realizes that he is the only
villain who was transported to this
floating fortress so he will be facing a
bunch of strong heroes on his own on top
of that he is unable to escape the
fortress because it is surrounded by a
powerful electromagnetic barrier and he
can't just destroy everything to get out
because of the ua's security system
which as you will recall has separated
the ground into different layers meaning
that chicago cannot disintegrate them
all at once that is when best genius
makes his move and becomes the first
hero to engage shigaraki in battle
genius tells shigaraki that as long as
he is using his mind and muscles to move
a strong current of electricity will be
enough to stop him at least temporarily
genus then reveals that this entire
fortress has been specifically created
in order to defeat shigaraki and
everything was made with his powers in
mind essentially this floating fortress
will serve as shigaraki's coffin in
disguise at least that's the plan the
way that the fortress works is very
interesting because beneath the surface
a bunch of heroes are working on
repairing the plates that chikaraki has
damaged and also potentially creating
new ones which means that no matter how
many times shigaraki tries to destroy
the ground beneath his feet he will
never succeed in breaking down the
fortress itself thanks to the combined
effort of power loader samanthos mei
hatsume momo and others this fortress is
the perfect place for the final showdown
against shigaraki the heroes used what
they learned about awaken shigeraki from
the two fights that they saw him
fighting in including the battle of
jakku and the showdown against stars and
stripes and so they put all of that
knowledge to work in order to create
this customized battlefield mei hatsume
played a crucial role in all of it she
was able to further improve principal
nezu's new security system and she is
largely responsible for creating this
flying fortress the massive
electromagnetic barrier that the
fortress is using is being powered by
multiple heroes who can generate
electricity with their quirk this
includes kaminari manga from class 1b
and others this truly is a massive team
effort and it really feels like
shigeraki is going to be fighting not
only a bunch of overpowered heroes but
also the very battlefield itself because
this battlefield was specifically
designed to defeat him now having said
all of that was anyone else put off by
the fact that the ua became a flying
fortress like yeah we know that the
world of mha possesses advanced
technology but making the ua grounds fly
like this seems a bit too much doesn't
it am i the only one that found the
sudden introduction of a flying ua kind
of jarring let me know what you guys
think down in the comments below after
we learn the intricacies of the flying
fortress we see the other heroes advance
on shigaraki bakugo miroko and sun eater
join genius in his attack on the villain
and shigaraki prepares to blast them
away with one of his quirks but he
suddenly realizes that his quirk isn't
working that is when we see that monoma
is there as well and he is copying
izawa's quirk and using it to erase
shigaraki's quirks just like izawa had
done back in jakku isabel is right there
beside monoman to ensure that monomer
can keep using his quirk indefinitely
and manual is also there to make sure
that monoma's eyes are properly hydrated
because he isn't able to blink wow
monoma really is playing a bigger role
than i thought he would in this final
battle and kudos to him he went from
being an obnoxious but funny meme
character to someone who is playing a
pivotal role in a crucial conflict and
he has earned all of our respect
unfortunately for monoma as was the case
in jakku the real mvp is our boy the
normal hero manual let's be real
manuel's eye moisturization techniques
are the real key to a hero victory
anyway all of this was part of isoba's
plan the elaborate customized
battlefield one of my using erasure all
of it but deku being here was also part
of aizawa's plan and the fact that he
isn't here could destroy everything as
the heroes prepared to attack and now
presumably quirkless shigaraki they
suddenly realize that something isn't
right shigeraki's hand begins to morph
as if a bunch of other hands and fingers
are growing on top of it and miruko and
bakuga are surprised to see this they
don't remember seeing this specific
attack ever before izaba realizes that
this perfected shigaraki is completely
different from the incomplete version
that they fought in jakku and in the
very next panel we see miroko being
attacked by a grotesque barrage of giant
fingers hey shigaraki get your damn
fingers off my girl seriously though the
chapter ends as shigaraki says that he
used to think that eraserhead was cool
but this has been a total letdown whoa
what is going on here what type of quirk
or power is shigaraki using to generate
all of those fingers and why is he able
to use a quirk at all when monoma is
using erasure on him as we speak is
perfected shigaraki so overpowered that
erasure no longer has an effect on him
or does he simply possess so many quirks
now that erasure cannot cancel out all
of them even though it can cancel out
some or is this some other type of
ability an ability related to the
physical procedure that was conducted on
chigaraki but not related to any
specific quirk
after i finished reading chapter 346
i remembered that one scene in chapter
341
it was a scene that i didn't pay too
much attention to back when the chapter
came out because i was focused on other
things that happened in that same
chapter but do you remember when spinner
went to check up on shigaraki as he was
recovering from that fight with stars
and stripes as spinner arrived to the
place where shiguraki had been
recovering for a brief moment he saw
some sort of strange monstrous mutation
that was just like a mass of fingers
growing one on top of the other the
whole thing was absolutely gross but
then in the next moment shigaraki looked
like he was back to normal although his
left hand still seemed kind of blobby
and weird spinner was super worried
about chicago when he saw this but all
for one assured him that everything was
on track and that shigaraki is
recovering according to plan so what is
this finger blob transformation our
first instinct may be to think that it's
just another quirk and all for one did
use a quirk combo that looked a little
bit similar to this if you think back to
all for one's battle against all might
all for one used multiple quirks
including multiplier and hypertrophy to
create a gigantic right arm that also
had multiple other smaller arms attached
to it but this was not exactly the same
as shigaraki's finger blob form so it's
possible that this thing isn't a quirk
at all it's possible that the finger
blob transformation is the result of
shigaraki's experimental procedure and
since it isn't technically a quirk it
wouldn't be affected by erasure but
whether this is a non-quirk ability or
whether this is some sort of special
quirk that is resistant to erasure one
thing is clear the heroes effed up big
time despite all of their preparations
the heroes still did not have a full
grasp over just how strong shigaraki is
aizawa was openly shocked by how much
stronger this version of shigaraki is
from the incomplete one that they faced
in jakku and the heroes clearly didn't
anticipate that shigaraki would be able
to use a quirk or quirk like power that
is resistant to erasure on top of that
the fact that deku isn't with them means
that the heroes are weaker than they
thought they would be and that could
spell disaster for this entire plan
shigaraki might seriously kill a bunch
of heroes in this fight this is no joke
and this could go horribly wrong very
quickly speaking of which i will
absolutely snap if something happens to
my girl miroko again she literally just
recovered from a major injury and now
she looks like she's going to be in
serious danger again as shigaraki's
grotesque fingers engulf her oh and if
you're waiting for me to make that joke
i see you but i can't because it's
youtube you guys have to let me know
what you think about all of this what is
shigaraki's strange finger blob power
and why isn't it affected by erasure
also why did toga abduct deku and why
didn't this trigger his danger sense is
toga going to try to make peace with
deku is she going to try to trick him is
she just so crazy that she doesn't even
know what she's going to do in the end
finally what will happen next will some
of the heroes end up paying the ultimate
price for underestimating shigaraki
don't forget to leave your feedback down
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more mha
content in the future do me a favor and
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
and of course subscribing to the channel
and hitting that notification bell is
also a hugely important way of directly
supporting the channel and it's
completely free you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at animeopror i
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to kyle salisbury this man is
an absolute mad lad and a disciple of
lord to ego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tier patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
alpha sigma in grata algital pate heffa
the red-haired fox hinokami and water
the toasted chi corey mcgowan spider
left tunnel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
and jeremy cummings finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews alicia octor bonnie
parks joy and garcia fatboy games kaido
might be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy
phillips and alivania if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you